solely from Disney and we are talking
infinity and new characters and Marvel
heroes and I mean if you guys weren't
already all about comic-con you are now
yes indeed we are actually at Comic Cons
with a whole bunch of announcements this
week we have announced that officially
the guardians of the galaxy are coming
to the disney infinity Marvel Super
Heroes platform and not just the
characters but a full-on playset the
full playset so that means like levels
from the movie maybe it so you're
actually you're gonna see a dedicated
six to eight hour gaming experience
actually set inside of nowhere which is
a location that you'll see in the film
when you go and see the film august
first august first opening night at
midnight showing yeah i know outside so
i just actually saw the film on monday
okay I'd read the script before and it
is give me your unbiased opinion will
yeah you're right they are everyone
watching hahaha I see everyone right now
is like oh yeah this guy no but I'll
tell you when we read the script
initially really this is pretty funny
it's all gonna come down to whether or
not the actress can pull off all the
different comedy elements and they did I
mean it is absolutely it's it's I think
people are gonna be surprised how funny
it is all right then how action-packed
it is and you guys have it going here
right now we're getting a look at the
the characters animated in game I are
you you know obviously they're inspired
by sort of the movie designs of the
character right be of dave bautista
voicing you know the destroyer over here
we have a great Dave Batista sound alike
ok and a great Vin Diesel sound alike
for Groot um the thing is that you know
the guys are busy working on the movie
absolute and so you know as important as
Disney infinity Marvel Super Heroes is
we want to make sure that they finished
their number one priority which is
making a great film so right now what
you're look as are looking at is the
opening cinematic to the guardians of
the galaxy basically what's happening is
Ronan is in hot pursuit of the Milano
that has all of the guardians of the
galaxy inside of it they have an
infinity stone and they're bringing it
to the collector on nowhere which is
this gigantic celestial head in
space so they're actually going to crash
land there after being a hot pursuit of
by Ronan and this difference of car and
troops and then Ronan is going to launch
a full-on attack on nowhere and then
it's up to the guardians of the galaxy
to stop this attack naturally naturally
and then Chris we take the fight to the
dark aster know yet so the dark aster is
Ronan's ship which is actually a super
cool design give me up stick it to them
you know and and then they're gonna
bring it to the man they are gonna bring
it to the man alright so we're playing a
star Lord here we've got him on the
platter which is no doubt not what it
called Valley all that the Disney
infinity base the base base how low can
you go so I'm there is star-lord right
now as well as the guardians of the
galaxy play set piece so guardians of
the galaxy is gonna be available at
launch and today we finally officially
confirm the launch date the launch date
being do you have any guesses august
first know probably in october cuz
that's when all other video game things
are now so exactly so if you were
working on this game would you that i
wouldn't want to go and I want to get
out ahead of our that okay yeah not too
far not too far ahead because you still
want to be in that like sort of fall
retail window does September 23rd sound
to you that sounds like a prat sounds
like a date so the guardians of the
galaxy place that will be available
September 23rd at launch to disney
infinity Marvel Super Heroes the
guardians of the galaxy play set comes
with star-lord and Gomorrah and then the
play set piece which gives you access to
the guardians of the galaxy play set
about a six to eight hour game 10 hours
for the completionist if you want to do
all the different side missions and get
all the different collectibles inside of
it shore and those collectibles of
course feedback into the toy box mode
that's right the toy box mode is back
and new and improved but before I go and
start bragging about the amazing work
the guys that Avalanche did on the toy
box mode this year we'll let you get
there well yeah exactly don't worry
Chris I will take this opportunity to
get there and brag about my guys but
before we do that last year a lot of
people love our fans were saying hey
what's going on with
the fact that Jack Sparrow can't go
inside of the world of toy story or how
come Buzz Lightyear can't go inside the
world of cars the reason why we did that
is because you know somatically doesn't
make sense to the story and besides
you've got this toy box mode where that
mashup happens naturally and and whatnot
so inside of Marvel stories though
characters can and often do crossover
storyline so they certainly do all of
our place that have characters that
crossover the Guardians the galaxy
playset am happy to announce will have
Iron Man's as well as Nova crossover
from The Avengers play set and the
spider-man % respectively and they are
going to have exclusive missions and
exclusive content story as to why Iron
Man has made it why don't we ever show
up in nowhere to help out the guardians
of the galaxy in their quest to destroy
runner so you will absolutely see that
always a helpful guy that Tony Stark
always a helpful guy and let's not
forget about Nova he's no schlep either
I have no idea who that is no I gotta be
honest with you Jon my marble knowledge
is am like a B minus a to b might as
well I mean looking at this table maybe
it's more of a B+ let's take a scan
around here because we've got a lot of
the heroes from Marvis from disney
infinity marvel super heroes right I
figure well have some Disney characters
as well as some Disney characters out
front of course Meredy and Maleficent
you guys announced earlier this summer
yes as well as tinkerbell which is the
gateway for my three and a half year old
niece to be obsessed for Disney be
honest I know you're saying you're three
and a half year old niece but it's
really probably secretly is it that
transparent seeing right through me
she's actually an incredibly powerful
character in the game internally we call
her the female Iron Man oh really she
but she doesn't shoot repulsor Ray's
obviously she's using a little wand and
stuff but she's got full-on flight and
that she also has a one she's got a
crazy super move inside of the game as
well laser attack all different enemies
on screen speaking of super moves yes so
this year one of the key things that we
upgrade inside the game was we added
skills and attributes system so mom matt
has a skill tree if I ever saw that's a
skill tree if you've ever seen
so now as your characters level up you
earn skill points and then you can spend
those skill points to upgrade your
characters different moves like you can
have you know you can have star-lord now
dual wield his pistols you can there's a
super move that he has ur he's got a
rocket jump he's got other ones we can
actually throw down turrets which is
something that you'll see instead of
filling me is kind of this this cool man
i want to spoil it i'll try not to be
already spoiled the whole film that was
it the whole way over here mad he's just
telling you the plot point and then they
said this and it was hilarious yeah oh
it literally was like that where it was
like oh my god Groot he's the heart of
the film and like oh so you know
unbiased opinion right if you're still
talking about something after the fact
that must mean that it sure made an
impression yeah I made an impression and
to be fair it's like I remember when we
were talking about gardens we first
start making this and you were like the
guardian like what what are the
guardians on i remember it was like me
christian we're explaining it to you
anyway when a woman with it so there's a
raccoon Marvel nerds on my team yeah
well yeah we're explaining like Groot
and Rocket to him and like I remember
original you like women he only says I
am Groot and we're like yeah and it's
like that's not a perv Indies like
animals like a Pokemon we can only say
holy higher is this yeah it's all
through inflection it's like it was
random like thing and like a lot of
people don't believe it and like when
they go see the movie they'll be like oh
wow Vin Diesel dis recorded like a
hundred different versions of itemgroup
armed groups so yeah you too yeah
absolutely i mean he says it was
brushing his teeth before girls go
tonight um alright so the characters
though going back to these the seal tree
and all these super moves yeah skill
tree in a super moose so that applies
not only for all the Marvel characters
they're inside of the game but also for
all the new Disney characters and and as
you would expect for all the old Disney
characters going back so what's cool is
that now you can take your you know
older Rapunzel character that you might
have had from the first version of
Disney infinity of course she works
inside of Disney infinity marvel
superheroes in the toy box mode but our
vision with this whole platform is that
as we put in new gameplay mechanics and
new gameplay features we our intention
is that our older characters will still
be relevant with all the new stuff that
we're doing so we're we're making sure
that the
this big skill tree is an attribute
system and all the older characters now
we'll be able to level up going back and
design an app for all the incredibles
all the monsters inc yeah exactly i'm
totally you explained it better than I
proud and and so it's so that way I a
big sense because if you go in the toy
box you know to choosing between
characters of course more than a couple
of them have super moves the other don't
yeah it's like these seem a little bit
outdated yeah so you guys are updated
yeah I mean and that's the thing is that
our intention is as we add new gameplay
mechanics as we add new features that
those older characters will take
advantage of those and unique and
interesting ways and it all comes down
to I mean just our developer on this as
avalanche software in Salt Lake City
there they're amazing group of guys it's
a big studio and they're putting a lot
of love and care into infinity as a
platform speaking of which I think
another thing that's kind of fun about
this is that guardians of the galaxy
specifically is developed as
co-developed by studio gobo they're
actually located in Brighton they had
worked on the Pirates of the Caribbean
plate set with okay for the first
version of infinity so they got to dive
real deep into the guardians of the
galaxy the script and all the different
film elements to bring this to life and
that's we talked about it being a
platform that's the idea we're going to
be bring other developers in to work
with avalanche to create and it was just
such an incredible treasure chest of ipe
I've Disney to work with it's incredible
I mean to you know to look at this table
which is predominantly Marvel with a few
smatterings of Disney and then to think
of all the stuff that you guys have
tread on already and then to walk the
comic-con show floor I mean boom there's
you know there's the vendors there's
Hulk there's I mean there's leak there's
some stitching corbel stuff out there
yeah spider-man there's all these
properties that are fall under the
Disney umbrella and you guys just might
must walk around these places and think
like oh we could we could maybe bring
those in to see you'd see a big line
over here I mean where you you know it
seems like you have this like massive
catalogue to draw from how do you decide
who's the next one I mean guardians of
the galaxy the movie comes out it makes
sort of a natural choice right I mean
it's out its out there everyone's
talking about the film feels totally
awesome but then how do you decide sort
of what
what direction to go in next because
there are just so many it's at it's
interesting that you say that because so
last year we ran a poll on our Facebook
page like kind of covert like to say hey
what characters would you like to see
join Disney infinity and the number one
most requested character was stitch
really yeah no [ __ ] and so that's ditch
man that's why what we never would have
guessed that so that's why we ended up
bringing stitch to the platform for
disney infinity to point out second most
requested character Meredy and then
Tinkerbell was in there as well so
there's of course other characters that
were requested but again I mean it kind
of speaks to we try to be really really
close with our fans yeah we try to be
really really close to listen to what
they want and and make sure that we
bring their characters to life on the
platform in a way that's a lot of fun
you know that that really is good strong
gameplay mechanics we start thinking
about how do you bring Tinkerbell you
know and make her a really fierce
character that can Rumble with the likes
of you know spider-man or venom and so I
mean it's a that's a really really
unique challenge yeah we're sort of
already there of not just of ability
right but also of kind of like tone yeah
and like yeah sure like it's fun to be
playing with all these differ characters
in the same game doing the same thing it
was interesting last year we actually we
saw that boys didn't mind playing with
any of the girl characters so long as
the girl characters were powerful mm-hmm
and then obviously having such strong
female characters like the walt disney
company has bringing those to the
platform actually attracted a lot of
female players to the infinity platform
so it was it's been a really really
interesting experience and as we
continue developing and watching how
people are actually consuming infinity
as a game it's it's wild to you know
work with them right absolutely we've
got some questions coming in over
Twitter here for you guys all right game
unboxing wants to wants to see some
crossover character up in action okay i
see ironman on the table here we're
showing off Gamora here but is it is it
possible you can see a little can't wait
is that is that unlocked right now man
no it isn't so um what is way now that
works matt i can perfectly explainable
terrace so how it works is
you may have noticed that in the
environment of in picking up these
tokens that have either iron man or
novaspace on it you collect ten of those
and then you're going to be able to
unlock that care to be able to play in
this place oh okay so it's basically so
we can get past like the tutorial we can
teach them using the characters and have
that tight scripted experience with
things that we know the pout the powers
they have simply have planned for you
know iron man who's awesome but you can
fly everywhere and all the Guardians
they can't so it's like a little
difficult because you know iron man
could be able to like fly all over the
environment yeah I pass a lot iron man
doesn't need to throw a barrel to
destroy a barrier he's yes abso ver
exactly so that's why we were like okay
well we want to make sure we have a very
tight experience in the very beginning
we wanted to you know give that tight
experience and then open it up so you
can play however you want to play right
I'll explain that pretty well you did
the unboxing here put that camera on me
game unboxing we will upload a video for
you on the internets that shows Ironman
tropical characters crossing over no
guardian we want to talk about my word
want to talk about these real quick what
are those so these are our new circular
power discs we added two new flavors
this one right here is called a team-up
disc Rick let's see if I can find the
camera this is actually a rare one this
one is yondu from guardians of the
galaxy so what I do is I put it
underneath the character oh area how's
it oh oh there you go yawn focus I'll
just hold it in front of you it's so
weird I feel like tapping this to make
it focus I know it's not good that's not
how this this iphone works so and then
the other one right here this is
actually a costume swap for Gomorrah so
I'm gonna put both these down so we can
show off these two new power discs so
what's getting them yes stacking them
two at a time so what's really cool
about the costume swap is it does like
the costume will only work on Gomorrah
herself like you only have the costume
change but can't give a fruit green hair
no can't but you'll get the buff oh
that's the goal yeah so it's still work
no lie yeah so this is actually her
costume primarily from like the comics
and stuff like that like right now so
and then as you can see above that
there's the on do team up it charges up
and then once it's fully charged I can
hit up on the d-pad and then he shows up
and starts fighting with me oh and we've
like announced a bunch of these like
there was iron Patriot's there was
winter soldier soldier thank you there's
white tiger
and practice this before you get on a
camera one of Chris waters we doing man
I'm just we're so sure yeah don't worry
guys I got so these these are actually a
new type of disappear also introducing
this year to these come with the starter
pack mm-hmm boom pull it in boys we call
these toy box games ulcer closer there
we go oh yeah have to register face so
last year our fans had said hey it's
really cool that you're releasing
characters like anna and elsa and
reckitt and vanellope but they're only
playable inside the toy box mode we'd
really love to see some structured
content for these characters so we kind
of went to the drawing board and we said
how can we create a game mode that
potentially takes place in the toy box
where it makes sense to have a character
like reckitt and a character like
vanellope alongside a character like
Maleficent they're playing in some sort
of structured content mode okay so what
we came up with is what we're calling
toy box games so these are structured
games that take place in the toy box
campaigns are about three to four hours
long and our intention is that over time
we're going to be introducing new
gameplay genres as toy box games so for
example the two that come with the
starter pack is one's called assault on
Asgard and it's a tower defense game so
it has this light campaign that's all
about defending Asgard from various
frost giants that Loki has summoned to
bring to Asgard now the other toy box
game that comes with the starter pack
since we've announced guardians we can
finally begin talking about is a dungeon
crawler and it's called escape from the
kiln no kid and so it actually uses
inside the toy box we've added this
brand new Auto creator feature where we
procedurally generate it actually uses
that procedural generation system to
create different levels of the kiln
prison that you then can play with any
Marvel character or any Disney character
so we've announced that those two are
coming inside of the Disney infinity
Marvel superhero starter pack and we've
also brought we've got to Disney toy box
games they're gonna be available in the
fall based on two different disney
franchises that you'll be talking about
I don't and I'll be talking about when
PR lets me finally start talking about
so these toy box games uh you know like
a dungeon crawler tower defense the toy
box is you know a lot about giving
people sort of as much freedom as they
as they want to
create their own stuff but you guys have
also introduced things that you know
sort of auto population things yeah help
folks along the way that don't want to
you know place every tree in every
building look that up here we're talking
it seems like the the toy box games you
know that's sort of you can you can
build a toy box level and it'll have a
goal or something yeah i can upload that
and share it yeah are you this sort of
games are just sort of those like a
longer form more structured thing is
there any thought of maybe letting
people chained together a few things are
sort of upload something that's a bit
bigger than just their current toy box
levels yeah so yes but we're gonna are
you guys ready where we're going in the
we're gonna go in the weeds here all
right okay so right now so you can
create a toy box right now okay and
you're right last year everyone's like
hey i love the toy box mode but placing
down each one of these bricks is can be
a bit daunting what can we do to make
that easier for players so we integrated
this Auto creator feature that allows us
to procedurally generated ments Matt why
don't you show one of these real quick
so if you guys are looking right now on
screen he's got rocket there go ahead
and press the gabba will pull up this
ribbon here now go up to the builders
and creators just so we can kind of show
how this works and as you can see
there's even more to ice this time there
it is alright so like I hit the tree
house so people can see this so this is
a treehouse creator when he puts this
down every single time he puts one of
these down it'll actually go and begin
blam procedurally generating a treehouse
that uses all the different pieces of
the treehouse and every single time it's
different he can go and use that put
that in a different location of his toy
box it'll build a totally different tree
house from there doesn't just apply to
treehouse pieces it also applies to
racetracks it applies to terrain it
applies to like throw it on a castle I
think that one's kind of funkin so we
pull this one up here and he'll go over
to the castle creator which is right
here the higher at town yeah because if
you want to build your own pirate town
you can do that so he actually this
particular the way that this Tool Works
she actually draws the volume that he
wants the castle to populate and pull it
area and I'm gonna do it out there
through out in space I'm doing a space
castle so like
yeah pull that out a little bit and then
here in a second does the calculation
automatically goes and it builds that
castle for him then he put ground
underneath it that kind of stuff but
basically in the past this used to take
people a very very long time to create
them sophisticated toy boxes like this
and now you can do it pretty quickly now
regarding kind of creating more
complicated things mm-hmm we have
integrated into the game right now doors
and the primary intention for the doors
was to be able to create la players to
create interiors so they could basically
build a structure place a door on it and
then go in and begin custom creating the
interior that can add additional rooms
they can add couches they can add
banners and you know kind of make their
own virtual dollhouse just a separate
area to not beholden to the geography of
what you see on ya outer toy box exactly
so I always say it's kind of like like
the TARDIS right where it's like you can
actually build just a small brick and
then put a door on it and then make the
inside as big as you want to now players
can also use these doors to link
together multiple toy boxes okay so this
is where now we're kind of taking our
game creation stuff to the next level so
you can build an entire toy box and then
you can lock the camera a 2d perspective
and make a platformer and then at the
end of that level that toy box place a
door that once you go through loads up
another toy box that is now the second
level of your platformer that you've
made so we've got stuff like that we've
added the ability to tag NPCs with chat
boxes to give quest text mhm it's all
done via clean speak so it requires an
internet connection but basically you
can place down an MPC type in what you
want the quest text to be and then you
can you know you can make the conditions
like yes I'll accept the quest no I
won't accept the quest and then once it
goes through clean speak so obviously no
one's writing something nasty sure then
it'll allow you to add that into your
toy box so lots and lots of more stuff
we're actually having a summit for our
toy box master artists summit yeah in in
there on vini all of them yeah we're
like from all around the world right
we've got guys from from the states
we've got guys from Europe we've got you
know the the two brothers from Spain
because it yes ma'am it's like it's it's
so anyway at that summit we are we going
like way in depth with some of the new
features that we've added to the toy box
to allow players to really create some
some incredible designs show the show
the racetrack okay this is like one of
my favorite one so after you've built a
world could actually matt'll hit a
button it takes a minute to do the
calculation but it'll actually
procedurally generate a racetrack for
you to race on it actually goes and it
looks at all the different objects in
your environment so it doesn't intersect
with anything oh and it will build the
racetrack and it will complete the
circuit and it will put AI splines on
the racetrack so that when he places
enemy race there goes so when he places
enemy racers down there they'll actually
realistically race along that track with
him so it's funny because in the
beginning like you look at this really
cool does you please put like action
figures yeah punch it to do no you're
right yeah and then it's like we
actually started I mean peeling back the
layers of anything like it's a pretty
sophisticated piece of software you know
it's like it's the disney magic right
it's like when you go over our parks you
know as an adult you have just as much
fun as a king's you're like how did they
do that so I mean it's kind of fun I
mean we're we're really we're really
proud of it and the guise of avalanche
have kicked yeah Matt's gonna race right
now in the autopia car as Iron Man
against lightning mcqueen I don't what's
going on there yeah that's what's going
on I mean against all look nice wow wow
well lightning to be fair lightning also
rocketed off the course so you know he's
a legendary racer well uh yeah we'll fix
that bug before it comes out September
23rd yeah so speaking of we actually had
another question on Twitter okay an
eager fan amazing junior 87 wanting to
know if there's any pre-order links for
the collector's edition there should be
anything like there should be yes so we
announced for those of you that don't
know we announced the collectors edition
entered into a great partnership with
the guys at Sony and inside of this
collector's edition is is the starter
pack which is typically $75 then you've
got
hawkeye which comes additionally you got
captain america and the incredible hulk
so we're actually not planning on
releasing the incredible hulk until the
end of october but if you pick up this
collector's edition you can get the hulk
at launch can Hulk out on sep tember 25
sep tember 23rd and he's one of the most
fun characters and one of the most
powerful characters in the game as well
and it comes with this big gigantic
diorama display that we've made that
features the frost beast which is one of
the big bosses from the Avengers playset
and the whole thing lights up and it has
bases where you can put all the
different characters and those light up
as well and even has a little seventh
area for another character that we
haven't announced yet these cheese's I'm
TZ's right so to you know if you if you
are the true Disney infinity Marvel
Super Heroes fan the true collector you
definitely want to pick up that let's
see very cool John Matt thanks so much
for coming on showing off disney
infinity Marvel Super Heroes September
23rd give me the platform run down right
here platform run down all of them
playstation 3 playstation 4 xbox 360
xbox one wii u iOS pc windows 8 taking
them all i think i got em all feat ah
and PlayStation Vita place T and Lady
Asian via but it won't be out on
PlayStation Vita subs over twenty third
PlayStation Vita's coming early next
year but you know how do you have a Vita
yes I mean it's a great it's a great
piece of hardware they're fantastic I
think we're gonna be playing some
spelunky matches in between all's you
know oh no I'm on vine died horribly was
yeah I'm that was actually the the last
game i played where I through controller
broke my TV yeah I mean that little mean
it's tough but I've seen that some of
the speedruns that people do on that its
front of it's magic it's incredible well
thank you so much guys for coming it off
I have a great comic con hear ya the
Guardians and all the whole menagerie
here very cool disney infinity marvel
superheroes